hey hey house compresses here to pack
five nights at Freddy's is that that
still things no one plays that anymore
am i right turns out no no every
everyone everyone everyone places
five nights of Pikachu's five nights
that [ __ ] everything they won't stop
till I played them all so let's play the
baby let's start with five nights at
weed - cuz I play the first one and
dammit changed my life
press ENTER over here no I'm just
present oh my god
there's a Snickers haha oh my god that
was a beer did you see that I just want
to Snickers please please could I have
the Snickers mr. Pierce please please I
have no quarter with your beer let me
have your sneakers oh no no I need the
Snickers I won five nights at spooderman
okay best game ever so this one is
called Phi nights at Freddy's 3 and it
says he hacked it from Scott's website
and it has two hundred and twenty-six
thousand downloads damn so oddly enough
this looks kind of legit
Hey hahahaha dammit your trick bag this
is way better than any finite so
Freddy's game ever my god way to
reinvent the franchise brah
there it is Wow cry night - Thomas - I
play the first one it actually scared me
let's play it baby oh my god it's a new
addition us by responsive but that's not
important
oh we moved for some legal reasons I
will I might tell you on some other
night thanks is a new security card
really
you'll be working the night shift yes
and I'm just here to tell you what you
need to do okay so show me your first
night it should be pretty easy trust me
so first of all order shine your
flashlight said all three the tours M oh
I can't it's pretty good too close and
if you actually see them you need to
close the doors
oh and don't use too
five nights at Illuminati seems legit
night one can't wait
[ __ ] it dorita power hello and welcome
to the secret organization of the
illuminating the robot doesn't start
moving until 2 a.m. but the issue is the
robot does a little chick
ok who the [ __ ] writes the script
anyways the robot a little buddy
and we'll see ok what is this dorita
powered furnace oh my god is your living
a day now thank God for my dorita powers
oh that was close I love naughty node
get away doom luminary Daniel Illuminata
head stop ah love naughty [ __ ] you're
with him naughty
nobody [ __ ] you this one is supposed to
be actually scary someone said the real
Stefano I was stupid it looks kind of
like what I expect from kind of looks
like the trailer or the teaser one alone
hello
hey who are you I don't know no one
knows this is fun
oh my god I'm having so much fun it's
the point what's the what's the [ __ ]
point
ah fine nights at Robbie's this is
quality this is how it should be done
I'm a man I'm not scared enough ah okay
here we go five nights at McDonald's oh
no you didn't tell me how to defend
myself against macdennis Minster yep
promise me promise me you will continue
my youtube channel alright poets after I
promise man so it look like they
stripped down a lot of things which
might make sense I mean they do that
some sub - I'm still very confused it's
just a lot to take in at once
cuz you're kind of used to the